kabul is on the brink what do you say
ray kabul is on the brink
look it's been i don't understand it's
been 20 years since 9 11 are we really
still worried about them doing
terrorism i mean look if they're not
morons and they learn their lesson like
hey it took us 20 years to get this back
maybe we don't have next bin laden
hanging out over here but they didn't
really
well they took the country over but if i
was taliban i'd be like look the one
thing we don't do is have terrorist
camps that's right if i ran a taliban
that's what i would do because now we're
back in charge they can't have look but
definitely tommy's gonna be like but
they're telling us the u.s is telling us
don't fall for it
don't grade point don't fall for it
you fell for it in the 80s you kept
falling for it through the 90s like
when we tell you we want to train and
arm radical elements of your society
don't go in for that
i mean has there ever been a country
maybe for i don't want to like play a
typical you know uh whatever but you
know france is it gets accused of laying
down for the nazis but like i'm saying
afghanistan they don't they don't seem
to be doing anything
at least all the american officials are
saying that like we trained them like we
like
we did all this they're not doing
anything to stop this the afghan you
know provisional government whatever
they call it a regular government
or the armed forces event i mean we've
been training them for 20 years at what
point are we like you know
yeah you got to defend your own country
maybe just one i mean it's a great point
michael tracy said on twitter it's like
how have we built this thing that
collapses in like a day
maybe maybe we were just spending the
whole last 20 years like growing opium
i also don't think we ever want any of
this to work
yeah
but we we we want a reason to go back
yeah well we want we want to collapse i
mean that's maybe that's the thing maybe
that's the play is that like look we're
gonna look we're gonna go back but we
need a year or two where it gets real
bad we're like we can point to like look
they're making the women wear dog
collars again we can't allow this like
you know it was too good for too long in
afghanistan
yeah
it's very strange and i don't know
what's gonna go down i just know that
we've got really a few peaceful years
left on this planet before it gets a
hell of a lot worse
um
and uh i just it's tough to tell people
that served the country
like the people that are joining the
military now it's like god bless them
i mean it's still better than working at
walmart i guess i guess you're right
that's a good point
that's not why he's not he's not getting
a job at ford
right
yeah i mean it's it's because now
there's we now know
like it's the proof is really out there
that like
nothing is is going to work
no i mean like
should i
should the armed forces now just have a
sign that says you will die in vain
like there's i mean no way there's no
way you won't dive in unless somehow
like you save a bait on one of these
missions that makes sense to no one
that's doomed to failure maybe you like
save a baby
and that's your good but pretty much
or you're chris kyle and you shoot the
baby right
dude so ben
ben
uh
goes out you know they're friends in
texas and like all the people here in
texas think chris kazaka here like they
they like they believe like everything
you know like they're just like they're
like you ever see the movie american
sniper
you ever see it
you ever see that movie zero dart 30
what it's a clown show it's a it's uh
they'll hate y'all hey jesse ventura i
think he's a
american scum
yeah so what was he's dead now right
chris kyle basically in his book said
that jesse ventura was like at some seal
funeral navy seal funeral and just like
saying the guy deserved to die
and like and got some fight with them
and like which is like even
look i know he goes on tv and talks
about the loch ness monster but i mean
the guy was like basically a seal like i
don't i don't think he's like just he's
been chasing ventura alive or dead oh
he's alive okay
yeah he's an interesting guy to get on
the show
oh he'd be great to talk to
yeah i mean you know i mean look just
don't ask him about the harp gun he gets
he gets a little uh
things get a little hazy when you talk
about stuff like that but why i think he
knows
he's just like he doesn't really have a
he casts a wide net
what the weather gun is that what you
mean by the harp gun i'm just saying
he's gonna have a strong filter i think
he wanted to fill that show up with like
you know
topic so i made some good points about
about 9 11 and some other weird [ __ ] no
it does yes i'm saying it's just you
know but then they don't you might start
going
but the harp gun is the real problem
there is a covent god don't feel like
jesse
stay focused i take ivermectin in my
[ __ ]
it's not gay
it's what's going off my navy seals navy
seals are all deserved deserve what they
get
shield team six was a bunch of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
bin laden's an american [ __ ] hero
how great would it be if he just went
completely insane
i love
bin laden family
and
osama
he's just doing like praying to mecca
yeah the only god is allah the only true
god is allah
he should open up we we should like we
should
we should see how far we can get
telling him we're like big investors and
that we want to open up a conspiracy
theory restaurant with him like directly
conspiracy fridays you'd get a meeting
like you'd absolutely get a meeting if
like you were like jesse we really want
to open up like a conspiracy
theory
conspiracy themed restaurant
like an applebee's or a fridays or an
outback
you know but instead of like boomerangs
and kangaroos on the wall we have like
syringes pictures of building seven and
[ __ ] like you know
the northwoods nachos are my favorite
like things like that
ultra feast yes okay
i mean we all i always wanted to do a
conspiracy theory line ice creams we
talked about it on the patreon but ice
cream is so hard you can can't do it you
can't ship it you can't make any money
i've always wanted to make my own line
of ice cream
that conspiracy hot sauce maybe no i i'm
sick of the sauces i can't taste
anything right now food is still good
which is how you know that like
you you have a problem with food is it
you can't taste anything food's like
still you're still looking forward to it
people like how can you eat i'm like i
can eat you just don't taste it you just
keep eating
but
i'm eating a lot healthier now i'm just
eating nothing inflammatory because of
the covid which i think in a few days
i'll test negative
um
but
the uh
what you're gonna call it the um
yeah i've always wanted to make a line
of ice creams and sell them but very
expensive
to a very small select group of people
like we'd have to literally we'd
probably have to charge something stupid
for a pint of ice cream
50 bucks something like that people
might buy it you gotta i think you're
right
well you had a great like we had some
good ideas about like jeffrey egg cream
where we'd have like
we'd have like an egg cream style ice
cream
with like um
like a fudge ripple and then like little
chocolate girls
or we'd have like the uh
sweet um
jet fuel doesn't melt sweet cream
and we'd have like a 911 themed ice
cream like we you know we had a whole
thing
controlled demo licorice something like
that joan bernier ramsay which had
beignets and they had a chicory coffee
swirl it was a new orleans theme even
though they're not from there but
you know